we thank the Glorious introduction and I
say thank you it's always fun to be back
at Stanford and it's fun to be in this
particular lecture hall I gave a talk
here many years ago so it's kind of fun
to be back knocking around Stanford
again uh Michael is right this is not a
talk about what my lab does if you're
interested in that you can send me email
this is actually me starting to think
about my next project and I'm really
sort of interested in starting to think
about our relationships with through and
of Technology this is really a talk
about the kind of construction of the
socio technical imagination this isn't
to talk about ethnography this isn't to
talk about HCI so you're going to have
to bear with me because I'm going to
take you on a rapid and somewhat
fast-paced Journey Through the last 500
years of History so those of you who
didn't pay attention in other classes
you're going to be really grateful to me
when we're done because you're going to
know a whole lot of people you didn't
know about beforehand um lots of ways to
introduce me Michael certainly gave you
one I am indeed the director of
interaction and experience research at
Intel I have been at Intel 15 years two
weeks ago my job there has always been
to bring stories from outside the
building into the building and to talk
about what it is that motivates people
what they care about what frustrates
them what's important to them what they
wish for for their families and their
kids and their communities and their
cultures and then we use all of that at
Intel to help shape the next generation
of Technology production uh I came to
Intel and kind of roundabout way I was
indeed an anthropologist IED my PhD here
I studied Native American studies as my
undergraduate degree and then in true
Australian fashion I met a man in a bar
in paloalto in 1998 the bar is sadly
long gone um and the man did not marry
me which was good also um but he did
introduce me to Intel and to a different
set of preoccupations but long before I
did that I'm also the child of an
anthropologist so I grew up on my
mother's field sites in Central and
Northern Australia I spent most of the
1970s and 1980s living with indigenous
people who remembered their country
before white fellas came and who at the
drop of a hat would take my brother and
I Bush and we spent most of well my
childhood not in school not wearing
shoes not speaking English and killing
anything around me that moved for my
supper um thus far none of those skills
have stood me in good dead at Intel I
remain
hopeful it turns out if you know how to
get water out of frogs it's a good line
for cocktail party conversation it has
not yet helped me innovate new
technology but it does mean I have spent
pretty much all of my life thinking
about culture and increasingly over the
last 15 or 20 years thinking about its
relationship to technology and when I
think about the notion of the fact that
my work at Intel and indeed many of us
who work in the HCI field our workers to
think about what that intersection looks
like right and to think about how it is
we shape Technologies and Technical
Systems that will in some ways comport
to humans rather than making humans do
all the work the other way around but I
think in addition to the Practical work
of building Technologies and building
systems there's also a piece that all of
us engage in and you will engage in as
you leave this building and you go into
the rest of your lives is that it's also
about shaping the imagination it's not
just about physically building things
it's about what are the stories we tell
about what technology does what are the
stories we tell and are told about our
relationships to technology and I want
to kind of think of that as the work of
the soci technical the work of the kind
of the imaginary new world that we are
all talking about the future we are
perennially designing for and there are
lots of ways to think about this I was
in England last week and William Gibson
put this on Twitter and I thought it was
a kind of fabulous line here is William
Gibson saying he woke up from a dream in
which he appeared to be entirely in
Google street views now those of you who
don't know William Gibson he is you know
probably one of our more distinguished
social science writers he certainly gave
us a whole series of tropes that many of
us operate in today when we think about
how data is configured when we think
about our relationships to many things
William Gibson is one of them who helped
shape those and it is fascinating to me
to imagine that here is a man who who
finds himself in some ways held hostage
to a system and a soot technical one at
that so when I think about charting the
soot technical imagination I think about
the stories we tell about technology
this was a starting point for me but
truthfully when I really started
thinking about this work it had to do
with this um so this is a piece of video
that turned up on YouTube at this point
about two Christmases ago so in December
of what would that be 2011 um it showed
a Furby most of you in this room are not
remember old enough to remember the
original one but it was a little talky
thing and its little eyelashes flashes
and its ears went and made a horrible
squeaking sound this is a Furby talking
to Siri so Apple's first generation
speech recognition personal assistant
object this is 47 seconds of video in
which predictably the Furby
goes and Siri says would you like me to
call Shell
Oil and the Furby
goes and Siri says something to the
effect of I can't find gram in your
address
book now this is obviously funny but it
also captured me and I couldn't let go
of it and I spent multiple days wanting
to show this video to everyone I knew
and I realized that part of what made it
appealing to me is that this is actually
not just an amusing piece of video this
is in fact encoding a very particular
moment in our relationships to
technology because this is actually
about genealogy right this is about
three different kinds of genealogy the
first one is this is a story about
talking things it's like granddaddy
talking thing and baby talking thing cuz
clearly the Furby and the Siri slightly
more sophisticated in that you know
generational trans
right it's also a genealogy in the
classic anthropological sense I think
the tree of humanity where we have
basically neithal talking thing and Homo
Sapien talking thing where there's a
clear and structural difference but it
turned out there was another thing going
on in this it only became clear to me
when I started to talk to the engineers
that I work with at Intel because I said
to them this is fabulous and they're
like that's nice I'm like no no it's
really very cool they're like that's
nice like no there's something going on
here because what we have in the
different between the Furby and the Siri
is the difference between talking and
listening the Furby talks what the Siri
proposes to do is listen talk also but
listen because the talking is a response
to the listening and as soon as you have
that transformation you have the promise
of something that listens to you it's
effectively for better or worse and in
this case possibly not implemented
excellently it is the promise of
something that has a relationship with
you cuz it's listening to you and
responding to you ultimately it is
something that promises to take care of
you it will anticipate your needs and
deliver something to you and I went to
my engineers and I said listen I think
this is
imperfectly pointing to the beginning of
a move from human computer interaction
to human computer relationships and the
what this actually does is signal the
beginning of a significant paradigm
shift in the way we ought to be thinking
about ourselves and
machines and my Engineers who are lovely
people said to me
no I'm like what do you mean no they're
like nope like why no they're like well
if we have a relationship with machines
nothing good will come of it like what
does that mean they're like well if
machines are smart enough to have a
relationship with you know what happens
next I'm like no they're like
death like I'm sorry how have we gone
from human computer interaction to death
and they're like it's really quite
simple as soon as they're smart enough
to take care of us they're smart enough
to kill us and I realized that what this
was also pointing to me was a third
thing right this was also about a
genealogy of anxiety that somehow we had
gotten to a moment where we could do
this in our heads we could go from Happy
perky Furby who really doesn't mean a
lot of harm to Siri whose voice
recognition to that because that's what
people were doing there was a slippage
and a slippery slope that went from
saying it's fine for an object to talk
it's probably okay for an object to
listen at the moment an object can start
having a relationship with us and that
object is a machine death and I'm like
wow and so I spent the last 18 months
trying to make sense of that because
that for me is a really interesting move
right how do we chart where that fear
comes from because rationally you know
Siri does not want to kill you the Furby
definitely didn't want to kill you
chances are goog plus doesn't want to
kill you either so why is it that we
imagine that they are poor tense of like
the end of the world or at least the end
of us and I realize that part of what's
going on here is what I actually think
is the first move that happens the move
that gets us to a moment of fearing a
relationship is actually about the death
of
magic and to get to that moment you have
to go back in
time and you have to look at the
emergence of three critical Technologies
in the 1600s late 1500s early 1600s that
profoundly shaped our relationships to
the world the first one of those objects
is actually the watch this is the very
first
watch somewhere from the mid 1500
talking about about 1530
here before 1530 if you lived in pretty
much any major Metropolitan Center
around the world there were different
ways by which time was reckoned
if you lived in the west you lived in a
medieval village or a medieval city
state town there was a large clock tower
somewhere in that town it was possibly
associated with a church and it chimed
the time it told you that it was the
middle of the day it sometimes told you
it was time to pray if you were in that
Township you heard time time was
something you couldn't escape it
happened you know over a 300E period we
went from time being a very diffuse
thing to clock towers that originally
started in churches and then become
secular things but if you lived in a
town which indeed was where most people
lived in the 1500s you heard time time
was around you if you lived in other
parts of the world there were other ways
of knowing time there were other kinds
of clocks in Islamic countries there
were water clocks those also made time
visible in all kinds of ways right but
you had to go to see that time or hear
it what the watch does is time suddenly
becomes personal time now follows you
you know what time it is when you don't
hear the time because you have the time
in your pocket and effectively you start
to be regulated by that notion of time
because there are obligations about it
as soon as you carry time with you you
have no excuse for being tardy if you
carry a watch not only does it say that
you know how to be timely but it says
you care about punctuality and a whole
kind of notion here of what had in some
ways been diffuse and free floating I.E
the notion of time suddenly regulates us
so Along Comes The Watch time is on our
bodies sure initially it starts that
time is only in the hands of wealthy
people but it turns out you don't need
to have that much time in the hands of
wealthy people before most people can
get close to time because it's like
early cell phones not everyone needed to
have them but everyone knew what they
looked like and everyone had made a
call so the first thing that happens to
start making magic disappear is that we
put time in our
hands second thing is a man named
Galileo riffing on some technology that
had been built by some of his colleagues
6 months before in a different city for
a different King effectively invents
something called the
telescope and the telescope makes
possible the second important piece of
the death of magic because what the
telescope lets us know is where our
place in the world is so in 16008
through 16009 through 1610 the leaders
of many European nations find themselves
gazing through a little tiny metal hole
into the rest of the world into the rest
of this entire kind of planetary system
and one of the consequences that of that
over the next 40 or 50 years is that we
suddenly realize that the Earth is no
longer the center of everything the
Earth is merely part of a much
larger planetary system and the
decentering of Earth and of us hugely
important intellectual
move the third thing that happens in
this same time period about 10 years
later 15 years later with again Galo in
play is the invention of the
microscope and suddenly same lens
technology what happens we become able
to examine the world around us not the
planetary scale but effectively not
quite yet but the molecular scale and we
start to see that all these things that
seemed unknowable can be dissected down
into little tiny component pieces and
what appeared to be in some ways
unknowable becomes infinitely knowable
and the first thing that gets taken
apart is an insect where we suddenly
discover there are all these pieces
inside the insect that look a little bit
like the pieces inside people and look a
lot like other things that we can start
to know and the microscope starts to be
a way of unpacking the world around us
the constellation of all of those
things of the personalizing of time of a
capacity to know our place in the world
and know what the world around us
happens signals a really important
intellectual shift in the post
Enlightenment World it signals
effectively the beginning of the
Scientific
Revolution a revolution we're all still
living in right a moment that said we
can make sense of the world we can know
things we can chart things we can start
to see the rules by which the world
operates on a massive scale and on a
micro scale and we can start to see the
patterns we can start to hypothesize
rules we can start to say when this
happens this other thing happens or
inside this is this thing here and that
thing is inside other things too and
suddenly what had been deeply mysterious
becomes knowable and known and the
project of knowing things of making
sense of things is a project that
arguably has occupied the West for well
nearly 400 years since
then but in 1636 and this for me is the
kind of in some ways the nail in the the
nail in the coffin of magic in 1636 Dart
says first in French and then in Latin
which is interesting so he's writing for
his colleagues before he writes for the
intelligencia he says I think therefore
I am
and creates the moment where the most
important thing about being human is our
cognitive capacity it's our capacity for
rational thought it's our capacity to
make this notion of the Scientific
Revolution true it is our capacity for
knowing things it's not I feel therefore
I am it's not I amote therefore I am
it's not I am God's child therefore I am
it is I think therefore I am and In This
Moment moving forward in the 1600s what
you see is a progressive that we can
make sense of the world and that the
quest to make sense of the world is good
one of the other remarkable uned
consequences of that move is that the
notion of things being magical of
unknowable things of things being
mysterious of things moving to their own
accord is done some people talk about
this as the moment we killed God which
is probably putting too fine a point on
it but there is a really interesting
thing here that happens as we start to
privilege
cognition
rationality science and we start to
decommit Magic and things that are
unknowable because frankly anything
that's magic ought to be able to be
scrutinized and then made sense of so we
have this kind of extraordinary moment
of the death of magic yes sir so all
this is really framed
around knowing things that are natural
systems that pre-existed us I feel like
where you're going is about Design
Systems yeah so if you just hold your
horses I'll get you there all right we
have killed magic and then we here
welcome to the appearance of designed
systems it's like you can be my straight
man want to come on the road with me
excellent so you kill
magic you start to create Technologies
and those Technologies proliferate and
from the 1500s into the 1600s there is a
proliferation of machinery and
Technologies built systems uh you know
to the Contemporary moment we know that
this headline not an unusual one your
coffee machine could attack you at any
time so somehow we got to that right and
I think there's a series of technical
moves that get us
there first one has to do with a surplus
of pieces so watch makers in the 1600s
and clock makers had what the tech field
would recognize they had basically built
as many watches and clocks as there were
people who could buy them and they
needed to expand their Market it had
also been a very profitable place so
there were lots of watch makers and
clock makers who were like well
everyone's built all the watches and
clocks now what do we do so lots of
people who are good with fiddly bits
know where to put their fiddly bits kind
of an issue and there are a series of
people who appear in the early to late
1600s but really this comes to the four
in the 1700s Who Made automatons Who
basically took the thing that was
interesting about a watch and a clock it
was self-powered it moved you could wind
it up and it did things and started to
reconfigure those from being Watchers to
being object and there's a series of
these many of you have heard of them
there are a series of small dolls that
danced when you wound them up they
danced there were little children that
wrote out scripts they're kind of fun
there were things that played violins
there were a whole series of automatons
but probably the most famous and I would
argue most interesting of the automaton
makers was a man named Jac the vason he
was French starting in the early sort of
mid 1720s he went on a big binge of
building stuff and he was really
interested in achieving the similitude
he wanted stuff that felt real so his
first um one of his many first things
was a flati a flute player and in order
to get the sound that a flute makes when
fingers hit the strike keys he realized
he needed to glove the mechanical hand
in
skin creepy um he used cow hide just in
case you're briefly worried about what
you might glove mechanical hands in in
the 1600s the answer is you know cide
but he wanted the feel of Flesh hitting
the keys hitting the strikes on a flute
right that was as far as he was
concerned important this object however
is the one that makes him well deeply
special so in 1936 he released on the
world something called lad digester the
digesting duck so how many of you in the
room have actually been in the presence
of a
duck okay good made a room full of
people do that recently and like
two-thirds of the room had never been
near a duck and I'm like how is that
possible like who are you people all
right so good you know about ducks that
is important because this duck is
particularly special so this duck is
duck size so you know ducky it Waddles
which is good um Vasa took advantage of
a new technology that appeared in Europe
at the time that no one knew what to do
with which was vulcanized rubber because
it was really important to him that in
addition to waddling this duck little
beak went clack clack clack he thought
you should be able to feed this duck
thought that would be excellent well
turn you know order to make digestion
sound right you couldn't use metal pipes
because they rusted so that was bad so
he actually made vulcanized rubber
intestines for this duck so far so good
right so this duck Waddles this Duck's
beak goes clack clack clack and you can
stick food in this Duck's mouth and then
the duck
digests now those of you who've been
around Ducks know what happens
next come on feed duck digest duck then
what
happens exactly now in order to achieve
the appropriate level of duckiness here
vocus had to do something because it
turns out you couldn't actually fake
digestion in 1736 that was a bridge too
far he had a separate cach inside
the
duck oh yeah so you fed the duck it went
into one stomach he collected duck poo
and the duck poo came out the other end
as the duck moved
genuinely excellent right I mean total
duck here is like as duck as it gets
Walks Like A Duck talks like a duck
shits like a duck Splendid right this
duck was regarded as being quite
miraculous because it was as duck-like
as you could possibly
imagine in the 1630s right it did all
the things we knew how of ducks do and
it did it appearing on its own kind of
steam its own mechanized motion right
vol said of this duck that without this
duck there was no glory for
France I know that may say something
about Vol but you know it is still nth
less an excellent line but this notion
of creating something real of attempting
to create something that felt real
hugely important right and here watches
that had been about standardizing time
become about how do we start to make
things real right and of course much of
the language about time and watches was
also about was time a thing that flowed
through US did it have a kind of spirit
to it so here the the mechanization the
winding piece of this was about how do
we start to make things real right so
this duck is the first attempt at making
things real unsurprisingly there are a
whole series of things after this this
duck kind of wles across the stages of
Europe for at least a decade aokas then
decides he wants to be taken more
seriously and destroys the duck which is
very sad so the only accounts we have of
this duck are the narrative accounts of
this duck and voler who was deeply
obsessed with this duck as clear
previously kind of alluded
to vocus goes on possibly unsurprisingly
to take his interest in mechanization to
make loom technology and Punch
Cards cleans up his act gets into the
real game right but this notion of
things that wind up this notion of what
it might take to start to make things
that look like real things important
kind of intellectual move right so can
we make things that feel real and what
the consequences of doing that you know
by the time we get to the 20th century
you know Freud at all are starting to
worry about The Uncanny Valley and about
you know Freud's not worrying about The
Uncanny Valley fr's just worrying about
The Uncanny and what does it mean to
have things that look like this and you
know frankly he's in no small part Ed
influenced by Edison's talking doll if
you have not seen that one you will not
get out your laptops right now unless
you already have them out you will
Google Edison's talkinging doll in
YouTube and you will see the doll she is
terrifying you can hear the doll sing
Twinkle Twinkle Little Star and you will
never sleep again
it is literally the most frightening
thing I have ever heard and she was
terrifying thing anyway so we start with
windup toys
right that notion of mechanization gets
very big and very impactful very quickly
so the duck is
1636 by
1812 June of
1812 there are a series of
break-ins in cloth making fact in
England men break into the factories and
smash the
Looms that is correct but no one knew
that who they were at that point they
knew the men who were smashing the Looms
that this was dangerous the people who
owned the factories were determined they
had a lot of money they had the lore on
their side they were creating a new form
of work this was effectively the
beginning of the heating up of the
Industrial
Revolution the men who were breaking
these looms also knew that it was
Criminal Trespass they were engaging in
and that it was
dangerous the people who owned the
factories got the police involved and
this became a fairly significant
moment interestingly The Men Who were
doing the Smashing knew that they needed
a
leader they knew they needed someone who
they could basically put in charge they
also knew if they actually put someone
in charge that person would be hauled
off so they created a
leader they called him
Ned Ned L sometimes General Ned
L 1812 is also the height of the
Romantic Poets in
England and the Robin Hood story was
just being retold again so suddenly
Robin Hood gone out of Vogue for quite
sometimes about 400 years when no one
really cared about the Robin Hood story
starting in the early 1800s Robin Hood
is back with avengeance we're very
excited by Robin Hood it's a nice tale
it's got you know the happy English
Countryside it's got despotic par it's
excellent right it's a good story you
know women being saved by men it's all
very you know it's excellent so General
Ned L takes up residence in Robin Hood's
cave in Sherwood Forest from which he
proceeds to issue a series of Fairly
didactic
manifestos it is also clear because
we're talking about 1812 and there is no
YouTube and No Twitter that they need to
work at how to circulate information
very quickly and because many of the
people who would ultimately smash looms
weren't necessarily it there was a
challenge about how you distribute that
news and so the people who created Ned
also created a series of songs and those
songs were sung up and down the coast of
England Pub to
Pub meeting to meeting and the songs
encoded where the Looms were vulnerable
how you could break the Looms so think
of them as basically hashtags I mean
this is effectively what this was was a
distribution of knowledge before there
was an obvious chain to do it and while
the loom Smashers were singing the songs
of how to smash the
Looms
the Gentry the intelligencia the
aristocracy the loom owners are reading
about the Smashing on page one page two
and page three of the times of London
where this was being discussed every
single day where there was an index of
smashed looms there were remarks about
the damage that was being done this
became the cultural conversation of that
summer uh Lord Byron one of the big
Romantic Poets um a man in some ways who
ought to be best remembered by epap
given to him by one of his many jilted
lovers uh lady Charlotte lamb once
described Byron as mad bad and dangerous
to know like the quintessential bad boy
of the you know early 1800s right he
gets up in an attempt arguably to
Rebrand his reputation and his Maiden
speech in the House of Lords is a
defense of the Lites and the Lites as
the last great Defenders of the true
English way of life now of course we
know these people because we know the
word we know the name of their movement
right they're the Lites we think of
Lites as being the word to describe
people who are anti- technology it's not
clear they were anti- technology they
were certainly anti- the loss of their
labor they were certainly anti the loss
of you know their kind of right to be
productive but the notion of Smashing
the Looms and of breaking the technology
and that idea that word has carried
forward for 200 years long past a
revolution that lasted less than 18
months so right about a month ago 200
years ago
so in August of August of
1813 uh Loom smashing was criminalized
in a new way it wasn't just about crimes
of property it became
a effectively an act of treason
punishable by death or transportation to
Australia surprising number of people
chose death
um to this day blows my mind although
the ones who came to Australia basically
jump started our Trade union movement so
we're always pretty grateful for that um
and the Lite movement kind of dissipates
but there is an 18mon period where all
anyone in England is talking about in
conjunction with the introduction to new
Machinery is the consequences of that
introduction it's a Machinery about loss
it's a Machinery about pollution so
think the dark satanic Mills is a line
that comes out of this same time period
right so Design Systems bring with them
chaos and replacement of things human
replacement of work replacement of value
replacement of Labor replacement of
meaning and the conversations about that
reaction are the only things people are
talking about in England for this entire
period of
time which is relevant because of the
next piece of the story about where fear
comes
from so in
1816 Byron he gets around Byron is
pretty much all about the next 100 years
of this story right so Byron and his
best mate and his doctor and his best
mate's girlfriend and his best mate's
girlfriend's half sister if this starts
to sound like the Kardashians you are
not wrong wrong um so Byron the doctor
the girlfriend the girlfriend's half
sister the other friend all go off two
of the Europe to spend some time on the
continent it's kind of a shitty summer
the weather is bad there's been a
volcanic eruption the entire of the
summer of 1816 is kind of a summer of
clouds and dust and bad weather and
somewhere in the middle of that summer
in Switzerland at a dinner party Byron
says in the way you can only say if you
were part of the British aristocracy
that he is frightfully frightfully
bored it would be awfully nice if
someone would tell him a
story that would make him less
bored okay fine so pretty much everyone
at that dinner party scatters to The
Winds of whatever you know piece of mad
real estate they are camped out in and
in that moment three of the most
important
tropes for horror are
born because Byron's doctor writes the
first vampire
story Byron's best mate's girlfriend's
half
sister writes the first vampire FS the
first zombie
story and Byron's best mate's girlfriend
who we all know as Mary
Shelly writes Frankenstein and give
birth to one of the perennial tropes and
Moral Stories of it turns out our day as
well as this day so Mary shell is a
remarkable young woman you know who she
is Mary shell is the daughter of Mary
wolen craft Mary wolen craft was
arguably the very first suffragette in
England she was a woman who in the 1700s
was arguing that women should have equal
rights to men ticking on any day now uh
so you know there is Mary wsen craft
advocating for that Mary's husband a man
named Wilson was the preeminent labor
historian in
England in 1812 and 1813 Mary at that
point was about 14 years old but the
entire conversation around her dining
room table was about the Lites and about
machinery and about the consequences of
making of
Machinery when her a boyfriend of the
time a man named Percy Shelly who would
later become her husband said about
wooing her he took her to see things in
London he took her to Egypt hall or
Egyptian Hall which was the place where
automatons were on display it was a
place to see experiments in mesmerism
and Viv section and early electricity it
was a place to see frogs dissected and
have a charge run through them so they
appeared to come back to life it was a
place of seeing all effectively the TED
talks of the day I mean I really don't
know how to think about it it was
basically like a bunch of TED talks but
with
frogs which you know may make a better
Ted Talk unclear so here she is immersed
in these stories about and experiments
in
electricity you know whole series of
European theorists are now arguing that
electricity is the lifeblood it is the
next kind of metaphor for thinking about
the body for thinking about what
animates
everything she also knows that you know
you can take stuff apart and put it back
together just not very successfully and
you know in the Frankenstein St story it
is Frankenstein as a scientist who
collects body parts stitches them
together runs electricity through it and
the object comes to life Frankenstein's
monster and it Lums Lumbers around and
attempts to work out how to be human it
thinks it's human it has a human brain
not an abnormal brain a human brain and
so it wanders off attempting to find
human beings to work out how to make
itself more human peers through a hole
in the wall and watches a family for
days but ultimately as human beings we
reject the monster the monster has
fairly bad response to that and oh what
does it try to do it tries to kill us oh
hello what should be an immediately
familiar story now this story when it
came out hugely controversial there was
an argument about whether Mary had
written it herself maybe it was Percy
maybe it was Byron but this story has
been in constant print since 1816 it was
the subject of some of the very first
movies it has been the subject of
television shows it has been the subject
of more spoofs than we can poke a stick
at and it is deeply embedded in our
Consciousness as both a moral play but
also as language to make sense of things
that don't quite work right we talk
about things being frankensteined
together as a kind of bad mish mash but
this notion here of human beings making
life and of life not really thinking
that's a good idea is a really
interesting and important story and it
goes on to shape ultimately what happens
for the next 150 200
years about 35 years later 40 years
later there is a man in London whose
name is Babbage he is a bit of an a
doell he is a gambler is kind of a
repeat offender startup before there was
Sand Hill Road to go
to um he created a plan
for effectively taking all the
mechanization he had seen up until that
day and doing something more with it so
looms made fabric but he started to
realize if you had mechanization maybe
you could not just reproduce literal
things maybe you could get to a level of
abstraction so not make a patn but what
if that pattern became something else
right could you effectively create a new
grammar or a new language he was trying
to think about could machines get us to
abstraction he is starting to create
Computing he creates half a machine the
machine is ultimately not built until
the 1990s but he has a plan for the
machine he publishes it it gets
circulated around England there is a
young woman who had been consciously by
her mother raised as the first child
of the Modern Age she had never read any
poetry she' never been exposed to any
art all she had read was science and
math she had science and math tutors
when she ran into babage and the babage
Machine she immediately recognized
something that we would all recognize
which is the machine was only as good as
the first program that was written for
it that it was excellent to have
abstraction but the abstraction needed
to be tamed and manipulated in some way
you all should know that woman because
that is a LEL she is arguably the
world's first computer programmer and
she happens to be Byron's daughter told
you he got
around she writes the first program
there's a lot of things that happen as a
result of this this machine lies dormant
in in some ways as an idea there are
proliferations of it through the end of
the 19th century into the 20th century
and in the middle of the 20th century
with the outbreak of World War
II in England the premier mathematicians
of the country are pulled together into
a single place called Bletchley Park and
they are given one job and one job alone
and their job is to crack the Enigma
it's to crack the code is to work out
how it is that information is being
transmitted by by particularly the
Germans to their various military forces
in a code that seems uncrackable by all
the previous mechanisms there are and
some of those mathematicians start
thinking this is a problem that is
beyond the capacity of one human brain
they need to actually create a level of
a capacity to think more than that and
they go back to babage and they build
what is effectively the first computer
one of the principal people architecting
that was a young British mathematician
born and raised in India educated in the
UK a man of tremendous mathematical
talent and rather a lot of social
awkwardness um his name as many of you
know is Alan Turing Alan uring is
incredibly important part of what
happens at Bletchley Park is an
incredibly important part of creating
the first generation of computation he's
also a character with Incredible
complexity uh Alan Ching was gay in a
time when being gay was kind of socially
unacceptable and deeply politically
complicated he was gay in a time when
being gay was thought of as a mechanism
by which you could be immediately
blackmailed so at the point at which he
was caught in a compromising position he
was offered a choice by the British
government if he wanted to maintain his
security clearance and the choice was
effectively hormonal castration or a
stripping of his security clearance and
an ejection from Bletchley Park and all
of his work he initially agreed to be
dosed with hormones he ultimately found
that to be a really unpleasant
experience and he stopped taking them he
was caught again and he
was taken away from everything he loved
he was considered to be a risk to the
British government risk to security he
was kicked out of Bletchley Park he was
kicked out of all the research he was
done and he was told he was never
allowed to work on any of it again done
for many people that would have been an
awful end of a life's career ultimately
fering it liberated him to publish what
is probably one of the most important
papers in artificial intelligence
because it's the one that kicks the
whole thing off in
1950 he publishes a paper called can a
machine think it is a philosophical
paper as much as it is a paper of
computer science it is a paper that in
its mere title is an utter
provation if you en title a paper can a
machine think even if you're English
you're rhetorically allowing for the
answer that the answer might be yes it
wasn't you know the machine will never
think or no machines think it was can a
machine think and the paper sets out the
conditions by which we will be able to
prove that thought has happened we know
this is the cheering test the cheering
test will be passed when a person
standing on one side of the wall can no
longer distinguish whether on the other
side of the wall there is a computer and
a machine computer and a person right so
the point you ask a series of questions
and you can no longer tell the
difference between where the answers are
coming from the cheing test will be
passed true test has not yet been passed
but its consequences run through
computer science as well as a whole
series of other branches of science
partly because what it says is one of
the goals of science is to create human
thought right we need to have something
that is indistinguishable from humans
and what does he think indistinguishable
is has to think like a person so you
know back to decart again right we have
circled back quite some
way what is also in some ways more
important is that this paper and the
question it poses end up also shaping
our imagination in really powerful ways
because this paper is profoundly
influential in science fiction and
ultimately who didn't know the touring
test you have't fact seen it even though
you all seem impossibly young because at
some point you saw the movie Blade
Runner on television and in that movie
there is a moment
where the machines
thwart a system to prove whether they
are human or not and they don't thwart
it by their capacity to think they
caught it by their capacity to have
memories to have a moral compass to have
an emotional core that movie is based on
a Nolla written by Philip K dick who was
an American author from the Bay Area who
took turing's paper and understood its
core impulse which was a question about
not whether the machines think but what
makes us human and the Nolla Do Androids
Dream of Electric sheep is an
exploration precisely about what makes
us human but it's also the story that
helps again reinforce and shape the
notion of the fear of the machines right
because if a machine can think what does
that say about us if you start by saying
I think therefore I am and the Machine
thinks
also there is an interesting consequence
for that
right so for me you can get pretty
straightforward from
you
know
dickart to Philip K dick you can get
from I think therefore I am to if
thinking they're not helpful so and you
can see that there is a really clear
reason why we have a set of responses
that we have right why we think it's
dangerous because we have science
science fiction literary tropes
political histories all of which encode
a particular set of ideas right not all
of them rational but all of them ideas
that have lived in our
imaginations in really dramatic ways
they have lived in movies they have
lived in political discourse they have
lived in
language they haunt right but what if
you were to say okay well I'm an
anthropologist and that's a very
particular history that is a slice of
history as narrow as the West that is a
story about the enlightenment that is a
story about Technologies of the West
that is a story about a particular set
of actors who operate in the post
Enlightenment post-industrial Revolution
Western tradition what if you went and
looked if you could at the same
Technologies in other places would they
create the same moments of
anxiety and there's a couple of places
you can go right you can go to some of
the principal scientific and Engineering
documents in Islam you can go look at
the book of mechanical wonders and the
Book of ingenious mechanical wonders
written in 80 820 and 126 ad
respectively these are books that encode
a series of mechanical objects so think
of them as pre clock parts but a whole
series of objects that are designed to
do certain kinds of work uh these are
pictures of water clocks so for time
telling they have different things that
happen so rather than Bells striking
it's birds that sing when the movement
of the water happens across a series of
objects sitting in these books are also
a whole series of mechanical and
mechanized objects to do things but none
of them are about vocas son's notion of
Similac they're not about for similitude
they're not about making objects to do
the things effectively making replicas
of things they're not about making
mechanical ducks that do duck things
there is a mechanized p a mechanized
peacock in here but it doesn't do
anything peacocks do because when you
turn it upside down water Paws out of
its mouth and that does not happen with
peacocks but it is something an object
where water pours out of its mouth
that's hugely important for Salah so
that you can have your appropriate
Evolution so you can wash hands and feet
before you pray and this object means
that the water comes out of a beautiful
thing the water never touches the ground
the water comes out of a bird's mouth it
is a mechanical object designed to be
part of a particular set of religious
practices and it is not considered to be
something that is faking life or about
to replace us and there's a very
different scientific tradition that
builds on top of this but what if we
wanted to take exactly the same
Technologies the same ones that vocus
uses where would that get you well
fascinatingly enough clock's got around
so in the 1500s there was a surplus of
clocks once you ran out of people you
could sell clocks to clocks became a
gift you just gave to everyone whether
it was you know socially or culturally
appropriate or not so a whole bunch of
clocks get shipped from Europe to
China as part of a whole right wouldd
like to you know give you things you're
going to find exciting so a bunch of
clocks that kind of went from
Switzerland to peing um where they were
regarded with somewhat of Wonder because
they made bonging noises if you wound
them up so mostly they were wound so
that they chimed they were not wound so
that they kept time they became
interesting after about 40 years and
were promptly gifted on to other people
so the clocks of China ended up in Tokyo
where they were promptly taken apart and
reverse
engineered demonstrating a particular
orientation to technology that arguably
has consistency so these clocks are
taken apart this kind of like how the
hell does that work they are stripped of
all of their inid the gears are
reproduced some of the gears are made
out of other things people work how to
make the strikes out of whalebones
there's some fascinating stuff that
happens right and there is one
particular inventor innovator science
scientist in the Edo period who becomes
really interested in this mechanization
stuff and what you can do with it and he
proceeds to take those pieces and make a
whole series of other objects uh these
objects have lots of names the piece of
the set of them I'm most familiar with a
kakuri so these things here which are
sometimes called automatons they're
sometimes called little robots this one
is a teacup kakuri it is a effectively a
teacup bar automaton it's little it's
about this big you put tea in its teacup
and it runs across the the tea table
when you take the teacup up it runs
backwards it's excellent it's beautiful
it is an object of Exquisite
Grace it is a beautiful thing and it
sits inside of a really important set of
rituals amongst the Chinese aristocracy
of the Tea Ceremony which is a ritual
about Grace and relationships and a
certain set of forms of aesthetic
pleasure so here is an object same
Machinery not about reproducing a thing
that already happens because there are
not tiny people this big could run
across tea
tables Distributing teacups but it is an
object that was seen to be a thing of
Wonder it was a thing of Grace it was a
thing of beauty it is recorded across
multiple pieces of the literature at
this point of these objects the man who
built them has an entire blueprint book
full of all the instructions for how to
make it um and the you know leading
roboticist in Japan got a hold of this
book in the 1960s and it took them 20
years to work at how to remake these
things but they said about making them
because they were interested in what it
said
right flash forward to the current
period and you see a very different
landscape for technology in some ways
same technology trajectory so after the
Edo period you go through a rapid
industrialization period looms the
mechanizing of silk production happens
in Japan the same technology turns up it
is accompanied with a completely
different discourse there is no Lite
Moment by the time you get to the 20th
century you see an incredible
proliferation of Technologies and in
some ways that are genuinely fascinating
I found myself in Tokyo 18 months ago
I'm with some of my colleagues and I see
this sign out of the corner of my eye
and I get out of a moving vehicle it's
the joys of being Anthropologist every
now and again one is compelled to kind
of do things that are possibly not
helpful because this is just I'm like
what the hell is this I'm like what are
those robots doing to each other there's
so many questions so I'm out of the car
I take a picture of this thing and my
colleagues from Intel kind of going what
are you doing get back in the car I'm
like what does it say like it says it's
a robot
Zone okay what does it say in the bit I
can't read they said oh it says is an
autonomous robot own and there are
robots 2 me in from the curb like what
are the robots doing like they're 2 me
in from the curb like whose robots
they're autonomous
robots what are the robots doing well
they're being
autonomous aren't you worried no that's
what the sign's here for it'll tell us
that the're 2 me in from the curb I'm
like coming one of those moments where
you know that culturally speaking you
are not communicating so I try one more
time I'm like about the robots they're
like yes it's the sign they're
autonomous I'm like who do they belong
to they're like they're autonomous like
what are they doing here they're two
minutes in from the curb aren't you
concerned about this no that's what the
sign is for I'm like
okay deep breath like all right can I
try this a different way they're like
sure I'm like were we in America there
might be some anxiety about autonomous
robots running around they're like but
that's what the signs here
for they like f you know guys know me
well like what is your problem I'm like
I think Americans might be concerned
that robots were going to hurt them and
they're like oh that's just science
fiction like the robots are our
and then proceeded to unpack for me a
whole history of Japanese television
Japanese political discourse Japanese
iconography everything from astroboy to
a whole series of pieces of anime and
many other things that we see the
glimpses of the technology here was
being understood as part of the Japanese
psyche as part of the Japanese landscape
not as a part from it and not as a
replacement to it when you look at the
trajectory of robot adoption in Japan
you see not only Rob robots in Industry
you see them in small to medium business
you see them in nursing homes you see
them in schools you see some of them are
deeply humanoids some of them are not
there is an entire Spectrum here that is
happening and it is very rare that the
language that is accompanied by it is
that it will kill
us when you go and push on you know the
kind of primary writers in the Japanese
tradition who are the roboticists you
know the principle one talks about the
fact
that robots stand a better chance of
achieving Buddha hood than people do
because robots are capable of infinite
patience and a Perpetual State of Grace
basically in the Catholic sense so
there's a very different idea here about
what it means to think about technology
same technology different set of
cultural discourses same Origins
different set of stories it gets
attached to so how do you start to think
about that together right well one of
them is to realize that not all
Technologies produce fear even locally
so my favorite American Technology story
of kind of stories of Splendor and
wonder is actually about the early
introduction of electricity in the
United States so as many of you I'm sure
know when electricity is introduced in
the US first it starts on the coasts in
the big cities people literally go to
see electricity so there were bus tours
arranged from the Midwest so that you
would go overnight to go to New York to
see the lights on Broadway that's what
that expression is actually about it's
about going to see the lights not the
shows but the lights cuz like Broadway
was lit up and was kind of nifty like
the great white way was all about this
notion of visiting electricity because
you didn't have it in your hometown in
the midwest so there were all these
places where electricity became a thing
you went to look at right it was
effectively a spectacle and it was
beautiful it was always extraordinary
right the flicker of light in the
darkness that moment where suddenly
things are lit that have never been lit
is kind of this moment of remarkableness
right and as electricity slowly marches
off the coasts and into the sort of
smaller towns there was a moment in
Upstate New York in Niagara where the
man who ran the local electricity plant
had a surplus of electricity there a lot
of stories of surplus in this you know
he'd wired all the factories he had left
over electricity he wanted to convince
the local population they could
Electrify their homes and truthfully in
the early days electricity was a bit of
a hard sell I mean if you think that you
know electricity was the infrastructure
the light bulb was its only killer
app and people already had light they
had gas they had Windows they had
candles so you're kind of like really
you want to drill a hole in my wall to
give me this uncertain thing and all it
does is give me light H so there was a
lot of resistance on the domestic side
to having their homes electrified
because frankly they already had light
and they mostly liked the light they had
and the whole electrical light thing
wasn't particularly compelling so for
people who were selling electricity they
had to find a new way to connect the
dots right so if he have this guy he has
a surplus of electricity he decides that
he needs to introduce the entire of the
people who have money in his town to the
Wonders that are electricity so he has
parties in his house as you
do he takes the ground floor of his very
large house and he lays track on the
floor fine grain narrow track metal he
hires a series of young women from the
town you can see where this is going if
you're paying attention he clamps them
into the metal track with
skates he puts light bulbs in their
hands and he runs a vault through them
now electricity in the early days was
only about 5 or six Watts so not really
particularly painful
and they unexpectedly because you fact
we know this they lit up so these girls
would skate around the downstairs of
this
floor with light bulbs in their hand and
a current running through them to show
that electricity was safe and beautiful
they were known as the electric fairies
which I still think has to be like the
best line on a resume ever what did you
do in 1908 electric fairy 1908 to
1909 um for a number of people for whom
this was the first time they encountered
electricity this notion of running a
current through your body was sort of an
interesting one right we hadn't quite
got to the point that you could kill
people with electricity you know the
electric chair was sort of lurking in
this period too but if you lose a lower
volt you could do this so there was a
moment in the late I want to say like
1910 1911 where Mary Aster had a dress
made for herself entirely stitched with
light bulbs and she had a metal
conductive plate put at her front door
and when the doorbell rang she used to
stand on the
plate and light up like a Christmas tree
which is really quite Specky so long
before Christmas lights she was her own
Christmas tree and for an even longer
period after that the kind of wealthy
households in London had a doorbell
girl who also stood on a conductive
metal plate at the door and when you
pressed the doorbell she lit
up I don't know what to tell you it
really did happen so there was this
moment right where technology is about
you know even in this particular place
like technology we almost take for
granted now it was about creating the
spectacle it was about a moment of
Wonder it was about beauty it was about
something delightful press a doorbell
doesn't just make a doorbell sound as
like a woman who lights up standing
right there I mean that's kind of nifty
in a terrifying sort of way so we know
there's this moment right where even the
Technologies here had that similar
affection now not all of them end up so
well um 1898 Mari cury discovers radium
good gets Nobel prizes good uh many
other people think radium is kind of
nifty uh it gets immediately named in
the commercial press's Eternal
Sunshine because indeed it does glow um
many people try to commercial it so it
comes out of medicine so marur discovers
radium radium moves into hospitals very
quickly as a way of actually treating
localized cancer it then moves out of
the hospitals into a whole series of
other things uh radium infused
drinks uh radium infused lipstick nail
polish blush radium
suppositories I know Sunshine
everywhere and a whole series of other
things right it becomes a piece of a
series of musicals so the musical Biff
Baff bof who knew um was actually a
musical all about radium it had a thing
in it called the radium dance this is a
grab from its program where the costumes
would dripped dipped in
Radium and then put on the players and
stuck them on stage we know this doesn't
end well right um and truthfully the
kind of fascination with radium comes to
an abrupt end in about 1925 when the
radium dial Factory in New Jersey who
had been creating watch face
first for the military and then for the
consuming public had um a particularly
gruesome lawsuit on their hands when
they had taken a series of young women
who are known in the kind of legal press
as the radium girls and they were taught
to paint watch dials so think about
those of you who are old enough to have
a watch dial there are numbers on the
dial M so they used to take this bowl of
radium infused material stick the paint
brush in it pull the paintbrush out put
the paintbrush in their mouths pull it
through their lips to get a fine point
and then paint the dials on the watch
the women who did this did this for
several years unsurprisingly the radium
destroyed their jaws and their faces
they all died of gruesome radio
radiation poisoning um and the lawsuit
that was taken on their behalves is
actually the first time we have labor
laws in the US that start to set a
standard about reasonable exposure to
things so this is why you know
photocopiers can't emit a certain amount
of radiation this became the test Mark
case that actually set in place a whole
series of things that we enjoy today
right but it also became one of these
stories about how does something go from
being wonderful to
terrifying in less than 5 years so we
know there's this constant kind of
cycling right of the things that are
Splendid also become the things that are
very
scary so where does that leave you right
well for me I think it's about a couple
of things I actually think that there is
a desire for magic I think there's
something inherently powerful about that
moment
the first time a light bulb flickers on
when you've never seen light in the
night the first time a television
flickers and you see a story the first
time you went to the movies the first
time you see a photo first time the
radio came on first time the telegraph
arrived the first time you heard a voice
on a telephone the first time we had a
touch screen the first time we got money
out of an ATM those were all little tiny
moments of Wonder some of them lasted
longer than others but there's something
really powerful about those moments of
it
being wonderful
where you kind of have that shiver run
through you where you go oh my God
that's so cool you have to go show it to
someone else immediately or drag them to
the ATM or turn the television on for
them or call them up and say oh my God
this thing it's like amazing right we
know what that feeling feels like as
jaded as you all feel you are you know
what that moment is you know that moment
of it being wonderful right and we spend
all of our time thinking about how to
design things practically whereas
designing for wonder I actually think
and Magic hugely
important Arthur C Clark another science
fiction writer has a number of laws I
find the first two to be self- serving
the third one is useful he says that any
you know sufficiently advanced
technology should be indistinguishable
from Magic of course he doesn't have it
quite right here right it's like any
sufficiently advanced technology should
deliver magic it shouldn't be
indistinguishable from it what it ought
to be aiming at is making magic possible
that moment of kind of Wonder and
surprise and delight and pleasure it's
not always about being practical and
pragmatic and solving every problem
sometimes there is something
genuinely beautiful about our capacity
to deliver magic and to deliver
wonder and I know because I spend my
time in this field we often spend a lot
of time thinking about how are we going
to get things to be more real more
lifelike more
indistinguishable from ourselves or from
the real and I actually wonder if that's
not the right
idea uh you know famous Japanese
roboticist says that the challenge with
robotics is that there is this moment
when they go from being very robot-like
to being almost human but not quite
human and thatness makes us really
uncomfortable he calls that The Uncanny
Valley that there is a moment where
things don't feel quite right and we
have all understood it to mean we should
rush through the uncanny valley as
quickly as we could and get to things
feeling right again and I wonder if part
of the way we might not get back
to Magic to wonder to the importance of
those things is actually to linger just
a little bit in places like The Uncanny
Valley in places where it is possible to
imagine the light in places where what
we might be engineering for isn't always
efficiency and practicality and high
levels of usability but also for a small
moment of efficient of delight of a
little squeal of Glee I think those
aren't bad things to imagine should also
be
the targets of our work right because
for me I do believe where I started this
talk right that part of the function we
all
have those of us who are teachers and in
the industry it is our job to think
about those things those of you one day
you'll get to design these things it's
not just about what we design it's about
the stories we tell about what we design
and it's the stories we tell about what
those designs will be and it's the
worlds we shape through our actions
through our words through our visioning
of the future that are hugely
important and for me there's something
really powerful in starting to imagine
that it's not just about the work we do
it's about the stories we tell and it
would be for me kind of amazing to think
that some of those stories we should
tell are also going to be about a little
bit of magic and a little bit of Wonder
and a little bit of moment of vocas
son's duck waddling across the stages of
Europe and of that moment of being kind
of mesmerized by things I actually don't
think that's bad I think there's
something about our fascination with
everything being explainable that makes
us forget that sometimes what we
desperately want as humans is a little
bit of mystery and a little bit of magic
so my charge to all of you as you go
through your careers here is that you
have to help me think about how we
deliver just a little bit of magic and a
little bit of mystery so thank
[Applause]
you now there must be sugar yes you do
you really going to let him ask the
first question
get PA the question wow so I'm trying to
think through one particular aspect of
this the the
loom
was a device that was ultimately I think
understandable for people who were still
against it perhaps with societal
applications uh whereas
Terminator is at some level moving
beyond this I'm trying to come up with
the term the best I've to think of sort
of like the homuncular Le like at some
level we sort of abstract way and say
this is doing something we can't
understand and thus you know we want ATT
to and I wonder how much of this magic
is lying in that leap you know we can't
understand what the robots are doing and
yet you look at something like Furby I
think a lot of people get the light out
of this even though it's you know super
simple State machine uh because it it
evenses some some signals that we yeah I
I think there's something about
nobleness but I also you know think if
you look back particularly at clocks and
Watchers there was a moment when people
didn't understand those either right now
the moments may have been shorter in
their duration so the early invention of
Watchers right not everyone knew how to
fix them they were mysterious objects
how did they know what the time was
there were all these rituals that
developed about winding them that are
all deep forms of magical thinking right
if I wind it at this time I me there
sort of activities there where I think
it is absolutely the case that
complexity is an important part of this
story right as things get more complex
and less visible I think there's
something about the casing of things
that make stuff more complicated so you
know when Frankenstein gets a skin or
Frankenstein's monster gets a skin and
all the inid are encased I think there
there are pieces of what makes that more
scary than if it had just been bones
right as it gets closer to other objects
sort of the complexity piece is an
important piece there and I youan know I
think there is something about as Things
become more
unknowable there is certainly fear to it
but what's fascinating to me is that the
fear precedes the things the levels of
complexity right when you talk about the
early kind of appearance of clock towers
and of Watchers there's already a
discourse of anxiety not yet full-blown
fear but there was a discourse of
anxiety about what it means I mean
people really weren't happy about clock
towers either there was a whole thing
about well but how do we know that's and
then the arguments about time you know
don't actually get resolved to the
international time zone conference
finally resolves it all in like the
early 1900s I mean it's sort of amazing
about how long it takes us to get to
Standard time we have you know 800 years
of time time and then there is
standardizing time and the arguments
about that are remarkably like the
arguments about web
addresses about who gets to declare what
has a suffix and what doesn't so I think
there's something about it's not just
about levels of complexity it's
about my kind of my working Theory here
is that as you start to impact our
relationships to time space and each
other those are moments when fear
appears and when you have something that
does all three lots of fear appears and
I think you know the Terminator Works in
some ways as a Trope of anxiety because
it
is rehearsing a whole set of other
things right it is referring back to
things that we're not even conscious of
right I mean in its replacement of
humans it is playing on the Lite Trope
in its you know bodess it is playing on
you know Frankenstein it's about you
know all this I mean it's its ability to
create fear or to be an object of that
or to be put up as an object of that
those all being different levels right
is because is playing on all those
earlier tropes too right is those don't
go away so you know the Terminator may
have its own anxiety that it creates but
it partly it works cu the implicit
reference we see more praic examples of
this like the the equivalent of a
magical incantation today is someone
taking a very specific set of steps as
they use technology because they know
that if they do it this way it does this
hold hold the laptop this way I hold the
signal better if I have my phone out the
window I always oh yeah no absolutely
and that's all about you know those
things never go why it's
magic
really no
okay she won't turn down the others of
you
though yes ma'am so I was thinking about
how how technology how we study
technology in our social interactions
like Twitter Facebook and how we're
trying to kind of take what we already
have from sociology and see how it it
expands in these feel so I was thinking
if you think that there is any place
where technology can kind of bring a
magical impact to how we interact with
other people or just something really
new and like like the peacock that
drinks water out of his mouth like
something really Innovative in how we
inter I think there's been moments of
that in the whole history of Technology
right I they've done different things I
me I think television is a chronically
underappreciated technology of magic and
wonder right you know not only did it uh
change the way we thought about stories
but it also changed how we talked to
each other what the medium of our
interactions was it created a whole set
of kind of practices and it did have
that moment to it I think you know the
telephone is certainly part of all of
that electricity once it got past light
bulbs is very much a part of how did you
create other possibilities for human
interaction right and you know
truthfully you know some of the stuff
around light is really interesting that
way about you know the possibilities it
created of being able able to socialize
after dark of being able to think
differently about food and food
preparation but I me actually for me the
stuff about Whimsy which is partly you
know the peacock is for me in that
tradition that one's a harder one to
come by we've sort of I in particularly
I think the most interesting experiments
I've seen with that either come out
of Japan Korea uh a little bit out of
places like the Royal College of Art in
London where there's an ability to think
that not all technology needs to be
about problem solving sometimes it's
just about fun and you know truthfully
think about you know some of the most
persistent Technologies services and
applications and you know Angry Birds is
more popular than the American tax
office website now one of those is
practical one of those is clearly not
you know Candy Crush the same right I
mean those are about pleasure activities
not just about practical activities so
there's something about you know we know
how to design for pleasure in the
content space we know how to design for
Wonder and Whimsy in some of the
industrial design space I mean there
were certainly you know moments of
visceral pleasure that people got from
Jonathan Ives
designs in the first generation of the
iPod and the iPhone and the tablet right
they were they were clearly moments of
aesthetic pleasure not quite the same as
Wonder or magic but you know there was a
kind of a pleasur leness to that so I
think we know how to think about that at
least in some ways in terms of
industrial design and a little bit in
the application space I think it's
interesting to imagine what does that
also look like in the technology space
in the interaction space and rather than
thinking that everything is about
practicalness when for me there's sort
of a piece about and maybe it's partly
that I work with Engineers who are very
interested in explaining and wanting to
make all the science visible I'm like no
literally put a lid on it people
actually want to have a moment where
they don't need to know how it works
right there's something about the fact
that we've come out of a period of time
in computational devices where the
devices insist on telling you everything
when you're just like why stop telling
me you're connecting to the network I
don't care I just want it to happen so
there's something about you know how do
we imagine a different set of
possibilities there that for me is sort
of interesting but I also suspect it's
one where we need to cast a net much
more broadly when I think about what Doo
was doing in Tokyo 12 years ago some of
what was happening on Sor 10 years ago
there was some really interesting things
going on in those spaces that aren't
necessarily what happened on AT&T's
network or Facebook
yes you who knew the answers to every
slide before I finished them yes so you
said obviously there are a lot of
cultural differences like for example
here in the west we have things like
Bill Joy's article why the future
doesn't need us and then in Japan they
have signs that say robots are our
friends have you actually looked into
any difference in terms of generational
differences like for example the way
people my age as a freshman in college
view technology as opposed to people who
have graduated college 20 years ago yeah
some of it is absolutely generational
what's interesting is while there are
different generational tolerances of
Technology the anxieties manifest
themselves in almost exactly the same
way so you know every new technology
brings with it the same set of uh
rhetorical anxieties um so and the
language is almost identical there's
some lovely stuff that was done when um
Congress was considering legislation
to mandate a particular infrastructure
right and so they're debating this and
there's this incredible anxiety that if
they met you know mandate this
particular infrastructure it's going to
make women and children incredibly
vulnerable to predators and it would be
bad if every household had this
technology because they'd be vulnerable
now that technology is electricity and
the argument was if houses had
electricity the light would be on so
predators could see women and children
at night and then attack
them you're like really and then think
about the kind of conversations we have
about the internet about you know when
electricity was first coming out one of
the conversations that went on in the
pages of things like the Washington Post
in the New York Times was that Electrify
find people's homes would be terrible
because they would never leave their
homes again it would be the death of the
family CU they' all go to their rooms
and never socialize it would be the
death of the Town cuz they'd never leave
their homes and everyone would just
revert to individualist practice so
there' be no more America you're like
it's a light bulb light bulb like you
know but it got this incredible kind of
work put on it I think what's
fascinating is generationally
irrespective while you may have grown up
with a whole set of Technologies the
next disruptive technology will provoke
in you a not dissimilar set of anxieties
because those anxieties are cultural
Logics they are not generational Logics
what the technology is that provokes the
anxiety will be completely different I
can guarantee it will be much more about
things like always on always connected
always sensing camera surveillance
technology not about electricity but I
can guarantee you there'll be a similar
set of conversational and rhetorical
responses to it yeah I'm just curious
you mentioned camera Sur villain it
seems to me that for me at least in
favor of the fear side of this is not
the technology to be afraid of but that
it arms people who you were afraid of so
drones and surveillance I mean those are
the trops clear now more than autonomous
robots well was fascinating is they make
clear one of the things that was unclear
I think in the 200 intervening years
which was that someone had to program
all the things right robots weren't
self-programming so if they were going
to kill you that was because we
programmed them to kill you or kill
ourselves and this been something
interesting about that pivot point about
where the next round of technological
anxieties are and some of it you right
is about who has the data but some of
it's about what does it mean to have
surveilling objects so think about you
know some of the responses and I've seen
just a little bit of it recently of
people putting Band-Aids over camera
lenses on
laptops of the kind of you know Notions
of what does it mean to start thinking
about our platforms as being always on
and always sensing so my my kind of my
working hypothesis here is that we are
going through a moment where the fear is
moved to a particular place but I don't
think it's gone from the devices
entirely
right healthy um I was just wondering
like do you think there is obviously
anytime we start having disruptive
technology that come that comes with
anxiety and fear but is there a point
where there's too much magic where we
actually should be stopping with the
iterative because it we are actually
approaching things where people should
be afraid yeah I think you can't stop it
right I think in the western tradition
there is a little there's a cycle right
where there's like this moment of
everyone is like wow it's like radium ah
Eternal Sunshine excellent must have
lots and then there's a oh that was bad
there's kind of a okay probably just in
these spaces right so I do think there
is a kind of there is an arc that moves
but the arc tends to move from a kind of
boosterism and an unreasonable
expectation and a kind of hype through a
oh crap bad back to a kind of a like a
steady state right
but I I don't know many Technologies
once they hit either a scale or they
have a real potential they don't have
something like that right and we're
clearly in the middle of several of them
at the moment right think about Big Data
we've clearly gone through the hype and
we are now going through the uhoh I
think weable technology still in the
hype not yet in the uh sort of something
about you know where do they sort of
settle out articles about Google Glass
yes well I think it's moving it's the
it's the it's the the sort of the early
adopter oh right yeah okay all right
thank
[Applause]
you